two
what's more off the rails
than me coming in
sick as a dog
and trying to do an episode
oh
[ __ ] bianca bro
that is too much you've gone too far
this time zach
[Music]
yeah so well thanks to our sponsors
kraken bnds upstart and stamps we love
love love love you
yeah so um
right after the last episode
i started getting the sniffles and a
really bad sore throat
and uh well theodore i think this is
just gonna be
what happens from now because theodore
started preschool
and now eli's starting to get a sore
throat it's like bro it's all over for
us
but i did two covet tests last night and
this morning and they were both positive
so just so you guys know uh
that's uh
negative this is sick i'm kidding
negative okay
i wonder is it illegal to come in
knowing you have kovit and
not tell anyone i wonder if that's
illegal
i don't know you might maybe not like
[ __ ] like maybe you could get sued
yeah maybe if it kills one of us
yeah
yeah who would it kill of you guys who
do you think would be the most the
sickliest um well ian already he's
surviving kovid so i feel like he he's
already
passed the bar he's got that long cove
for some reason i feel like zach would
die
oh how sweet thank you ethan i mean it's
not it's nothing personal it's just a
guess yeah i i would guess because zach
smokes
[Music]
and
zach was telling me that um nicotine
actually uh fights off cobia i'm sure it
does yeah he was explaining yeah you
know what else i heard uh fights off
kovid uh pizza
so yeah that's good i'll just take some
ivermector i'll be fine yeah
no i don't have covert i made extra sure
but i was like the timing was so messed
up because we just took this week off
and i'm like i'll be god damned
if um
we're gonna miss another show and the
thing that really
frustrates me
is that tomorrow morning at nine and
nine a.m we're supposed to shoot our new
show
that we've been hyping up for like
the whole year at this point and i was
like if i have to cancel that i might as
well just i might as well just cancel
the whole show if i have to cancel again
because we've canceled filming like
three times god twice it was only twice
that we canceled i think
did we oh i think we had two cancels in
one delay
yeah three times can't keep track of
this [ __ ]
i was like bro if this uh i can't do
this again so
we're just gonna push through it
no covet though
what i'm gonna do well today anyway
we're gonna do a short
uh episode here today i just wanted to
get out here and
do my duties
do like an hour
and um call it a day so that i'm
hopefully feeling up i can go home and
rest for tomorrow
but there is a special occasion today
actually
young zachary the sound god
is 24 years old
wow that is correct i am 24
years old
this is the big one this is a young
you're a young young man yeah yeah i'm
uh 24. i can't rent a car yet so that
kind of sucks but i'm a loser
but yeah 24. you can rent the car you
just get horrible rates
i thought you you have to be 25. no you
can it's just horrible rates until
you're 25. i don't know why that is i
remember when ela came the first time we
rented a car
and we were both under 25
but we didn't we had no option it dude
it was like
300 a day
we rented a car for a week and spent
like every
cent that we had just so we could travel
around yeah it's crazy it's like 10
times more expensive
well i guess i can go get a
convertible mustang right now so
happy birthday to me yeah well next next
year we should rent you a car for the
day
just to celebrate i'm actually seeing
specifically you can rent a car in the
u.s if you're 21 and older but
the rental companies won't rent you
nice cars so
you get beaters yeah they give you the
shittiest car well i mean i mean listen
i know it wasn't that bad of a driver
why the hate i don't know why this
ageism
reverse ageism hertz renters under 25
may rent any car except those from the
dream cars prestige and adrenaline
collections
it's probably a good idea
by the way let's be real what's in her
adrenaline collection
you know what i mean a question too
like a v4 instead of a v2
yeah
but look um but anyway zach we actually
prepared something for your birthday
uh a.b you're uh
so we wanted to
fulfill a fantasy for you
oh wow wonder what
what could it be
we got a guitar where is he going to do
this
i guess um
we'll uh i can move my camera
yeah we could do it right over here
we bought we got you the cheapest guitar
we could find
and there's a gift inside and you have
to smash the guitar oh no way yep that's
right oh [ __ ]
pack the rock and roller
oh my god
i'm glad it's a cheap guitar yeah yeah
yeah don't worry okay it was like 100
bucks okay so where should i do this i
think we'll do it out over uh in the
main floor of the studio over here oh
thank you so much but you got to do so
what i want to see from you
is shred your hardest lick because then
you you can't just smash it you have to
shred your hottest lick like this guitar
is too [ __ ] hot he's right
you couldn't have tuned it first
[Laughter]
yeah
close enough
all right so
you want me to shred a hot lick right a
hot lick and smash that [ __ ] right to
it
i think you're a little rusty
you gotta learn how to tune i could take
the guitar is a little rusty
anyway zack
this is so sweet a tribute to the guitar
gods
[Music]
zack said
oh
okay
three hits not much cracking actually
zach what kind of rock
there it is
oh
exploded
wow
so zach smashed
zach smashed the guitar the the bottom
blew out now he's got the envelope that
was uh hidden inside go ahead oh
configurating can you give yourself a uh
a drum roll how do you feel zack
amazing yeah i like that invigorating
good
was it harder to break than you thought
i feel like
if it was a higher end guitar it would
be but because those are made with such
cheap wood
it might have been a little easier
interesting true
all right you want me to open this up go
ahead
what do we got here
is it a hooters gift card again
even better
gift for you fifty dollars penny rolex
authorized hold it up to the camera
yeah we figured we could get you on your
way
obviously i'm not going to spend 10
grand on a rolex yet
but i figured we'd get you on your way
with a 50
wow thank you very much i do appreciate
that thank you so you're uh you're about
like one
i don't know half of a percent
yeah pretty much my way to buying a
rolex you know this is funny this is the
one i actually want it's the kermit
oh mariners so good inspiration thank
you very much i do appreciate you very
welcome and by the way that's not a real
gift certificate either yeah it turns
out rolex doesn't offer gift cards i
think that's a little below them so we i
wasn't gonna buy you a real one but it
turns out uh yeah they're like listen
you just gotta buy the [ __ ] watch
i scoured santiali this morning looking
for a fake rolex oh you couldn't find it
i couldn't surprising yep yeah we wanted
to buy you a fake one but and all of
that i mean i'm just shocked by that but
thank you for trying olivia yeah thank
you i do appreciate this thank you so
much happy birthday zach thank you very
much i do appreciate that
ah zach sweet zack
yeah
yeah you had a live show too you can
play a little clip of that
yeah that was a little played a live
show and i guess a lot of flooper
troopers showed up eh and all you guys
were there there was a great crowd there
it was awesome it was really cool
meeting everyone
interesting
[Music]
was it admissions after a free show
no there was a ticket sales of the door
you made money
i made a little amount of money that i
gave to the band
oh sweetheart how much you make
a couple hundred few hundred dollars
that's great yeah
he sold out i mean it was huge
wait you called michelle out no i mean
like
he's does he charge a couple bucks dude
i mean how's that selling out
this show was out the door is what i
mean
hell yeah
looks fun
[Music]
there's a great crowd
yeah people were amped
[Applause]
indoors
it was indoors oh you guys
[Applause]
it's a lot of masks
[Music]
[Applause]
it was amazing it was fun to be playing
again
[Applause]
he's awesome
who's that film you that's my girlfriend
oh okay for some reason she looked
different way
look at that shred bro your nails are
glowing yeah it was
oh no
have that person bounce
them out yeah but you know they're
they're gonna get that i know you're
gonna get that forever i know
if you become a rock star people can be
screaming
clyden's clean water [ __ ] to you all day
flight is cold water blind water
got some spongebob merch from audio
yeah it looks fun good for you
yeah stay tuned guys i guess you'll
probably be doing another one of those
soon yeah that was a lot of fun i
appreciate everyone coming out and uh
the crew come in and it was a great time
zach would have killed me if i didn't
come yeah i would have like literally
would have stabbed me to death in an
alley
but yeah it was a lot of fun dan was
very to himself he was like a lot of
people he was very he went to the back
we were that trailer
we we got so we got swarmed
daniel we're keeping a low profile
he's being professional i guess i mean i
feel like you i don't really know what
maybe he's talking about i feel like you
weren't enjoying the attention as much
as
me and zach were
yeah i i i i enjoying the attention what
do you mean
he's like yes come to me we were signing
autographs and hoodies and it was
awesome
i do get a little anxious in crowds so
i'm not uh i'm not necessarily reveling
in it like some people oh yeah but but
you know i i said hate lots of fans and
i signed some autographs some
girl came with a twilight dvd and
actually got the entire cast to sign it
wow she came up to me and she was like
can you sign my twilight dvd i'm like
you got the wrong guy that's a b and
she's like i already got him i need i
need yours now just saying we had to
when everyone got there i had to like
book them back to the green room because
there was just swarms of
you guys got to go to the green room
yeah it was really
no hate to the mint but a very strange
uh vibe in the green room really why is
that why
what you didn't det you didn't feel
those strange vibes we were all talking
about it rock and roll back me up what
was the strange vibe it smelled like a
new car i thought
it did not always a new car it
absolutely smelled like 40 years of
cigarettes is what it smelled like it
was cool you could smoke in there a new
car vibe that's what that's what a green
room should spa i'm with zach there was
some there's a weird vibe in there
someone definitely got killed in there
or something or sex there's been lots of
you're wearing you're with me not zach
yes oh i said yeah i'm sorry there's a
lot of stains on that couch yeah right
okay well sounds like you guys all had
fun so it was fun
yeah so anyway mega awesome nerd one of
our mods
good guy
[Music]
made this deep fake i haven't seen this
but
it's apparently me
and cav cav
and it's not loading
is read it down i just feel like i was
trying to load it on my phone oh it's
working
don't do this to us write it i don't
know don't do this to us
let's see oh maybe it is it's not
loading uh-oh
i'm busted all right well [ __ ] that then
we'll skip that [ __ ]
sorry mega hopefully we don't have too
many uh what is this nicole richie the
simple life girl her hair set on fire uh
yeah
sweet
[Applause]
death to the death to the videoer why
did it stop there
i
know hello why did it stop there
death to all of them
death to the cameraman that's on that is
unacceptable
that you would stop the video there also
i have to comment on the
the the death to all of them meme
it's very
it's a great meme but i've seen multiple
people now say that they've gotten in
seriously like gotten banned from reddit
and stuff for reusing that meme
because people think it's serious and
they don't know the reference and it
just seems like you're sending death
threats to somebody so you got to be
careful where you deploy the death to
all of them to all of them yeah and good
company because you're literally just
wishing death
so like if you just say that you're just
going to sound like isis bro
love confirm reddit's down for him too
so it's not just us uh i guess reddit's
uh yeah don't go around wishing death to
everyone yeah you're very unless you
know
with the deployment yeah death to all of
them yeah
but in this case death to all of them
i mean how would you stop the how would
you stop it there that's not that's
unacceptable
ruins the video all right clap if you
think she should suffer yeah
[Applause]
you know it's interesting both sides
actually lit on fire
wait really yeah look both she caught
both sides
yeah oh my god i didn't even know like
damn you suck bro
what does she put in her hair gasoline
yeah doesn't say it's probably her hair
product probably flammable
should she suffer
oh
that's brutal
40 huh
yeah
oh
i didn't even notice that wow
she's 40. this is 40. dude damn i know
that's crazy
too way too old for keemstar
she looks great though
[Music]
way too old for him
roll it
roll it actually there's a new keemstar
meme
oh my god you guys this is too much for
me he he
i don't can someone explain to me what
he's thinking because he keeps leaning
into this i'm a creepy old dude who
hangs out with like
like uh high school girls
and
i think it's actually harming him at
this point like online like it's it's
disgusting i mean
all of his replies are just making fun
of him at this point i mean even 100
even someone like faze blanks has got to
be thinking twice about his relationship
with keem where it's like here i am
sitting across from a dude who's openly
i mean he's let's be honest he's preying
on them
he's he has an open casting call he
probably has a casting couch at home
where he cannot
i mean i wouldn't be surprised
but anyway here's a new video
roll it
that he posted on twitter and it's like
bro what are you doing watching this one
oh boy and it's it's tough it's tough
this one is tough yeah
she's got your pots in
she has no idea
[Laughter]
you know
what can you say
it hurts
it hurts that one it's been a while
since i've seen something that really
made me physically cringe yeah so
apparently this is his 20 year old
assistant
and their best friends he says they're
we're best friends
and it was used in a book huh
and so she has ear she has airpods on
and she's just having the time of her
life i mean no hater she's 20 year old
girl that's how you know young people
act
but
keemstar
you gotta keep busted this this is
actually friendly advice now
i'm giving you good advice you need to
keep your midlife crisis offline
yeah i mean it's something and i and i
mean that with peace and love i'm trying
i'm this is honest good advice to you
yeah
keep your midlife crisis offline
posting this makes you look
so [ __ ] bad keemstar shut up
[Music]
you know
it's not good it's not a good look
you're hanging out with 20 year old
girls you're giggling i mean it's not a
good look you're almost 40 man
people in the comments go i i honestly
don't know if that's hurt his daughter
or his girlfriend
again i don't say this no hate to her at
all yeah no
but she looks
very young
she's she's fresh out of high school
yeah
you know
and she doesn't know better i mean what
does she know she's having fun she's
hanging out with this
celeb
[Music]
huh
you know they're drinking like milk
together
do you think she covers her milk when
when she leaves the room brings her milk
with her
what
just because there's particles in the
air right right
[Music]
yeah if i was having milk at keemstar's
house i'd bring the milk with me to the
bathroom
because i'd like to continue drinking it
because it's such a nice beverage i
wouldn't want to leave it alone he lives
in a very rural area there's a lot of
yeah they love milk all right i wouldn't
leave my milk with keemstar and i'll
tell you why because i would be afraid
he would drink it because it's so good
oh god what is this picture
i'll just you know set a visual of what
show me is this is this his assistant
yes
oh she has braces perfect
he looks like his daughter
[Music]
you want this keemstar cop oh easy come
on
brother help me
and i mean just the idea of a 40 year
old man who who could be
you know in the headspace to say to a 20
year old girl fresh out of high school
you're my best friend
do you really say that i think well i
don't know i remember something like
them saying we're each other's best
friends
but yeah keemstar keep the midlife
crisis offline i swear bro i'm just
trying to help you
we don't i don't take any pleasure in
seeing this
she's got earpods in
she has no idea
i mean if that was his daughter that
would be like kind of an awesome video
yeah yeah
but he's trying to [ __ ] her let's be
honest oh god
for sure i mean come on
jesus
what does keemstar need an assistant for
anyway like
um
well what keep what is getting his hairs
for man
cuz what i don't know i'm not even gonna
go there yeah never mind
i don't know where you're going well i
mean what yeah what would you do run to
the store and get some uh
some dye for the beard
some milk yeah pick up a mess up i mean
what the [ __ ] do you need an assistant
for bro
uh semen is a kind of milk
stop it zach
unfortunately if you want my real answer
it's so that there's another
young woman around so that when the
young women that he's trying to date
come around there's like somebody that
can talk to them oh you think it's like
a grooming thing like a wingman
woman
oh i didn't even think about that
devious
i think he's 100 right it's like a romeo
julia
see that that that theory disturbs me
because it's like the effort that and
the forethought that goes into grooming
young girls
not of age girls let's be honest but you
could broom groom broom
he
most predators
groom he brooms
if you have the intellect for it i could
see him having a cult like oh yeah right
who the [ __ ] going to buy this i'm
saying he doesn't have it but if he did
i could see him with like
five young girls around him and he's got
the look alright he doesn't got that r
kelly [ __ ]
no
did you have your g fuel
[Music]
how it is ghost hey
do you have your g-fuel
do you have permission from your parents
did you get your shots do you have your
girl would you like to come four
wheelers with keemstar
with keemstar
do you have your permission slip
did you drink your g fuel girl would you
like to come ride four wheelers with
keemstar
[Music]
do your family know your last
whereabouts
[Music]
[Music]
oh you really breathe new life into that
one
i love that song that song will live
forever it really will let's read the
comments i'm sure they're good
oh oh no
not keem writing another email
oh
susan
we're busted
dear susan
i've written to you so many times this
past month
and you still haven't answered my email
ethan continues
to goof on me
20 years
20 years old is legal
susan
why should that be any thing to make fun
of
she helps me keep my four-wheelers clean
there's no funny business
[Music]
and when we're done
we like to watch
my little pony together
any count chocula
and pretend it's saturday morning
and watch cartoons
[Music]
i don't know
anyway susan you gotta stop it end this
this abuse
uh reddit is back up if you wanted to
circle back to that video
wait when we look these are the comments
it's like unrelated like what the [ __ ]
is this
roll it this was a brilliant response
ludwig
no this is a different post
so confused oh god
yeah it's a new twitter update it sucks
didn't we click to see the comments
okay here we go click under it and back
up
roll it
no i don't want more tweets damn it
what's it's when is that a thing
yeah i i guess well some father-daughter
moment that's what you would think
it's not his daughter
is that your daughter for real no
holy [ __ ] keeps that your daughter has
grown up so quick yeah it's not her
daughter
i don't know how many times i need to
tell you guys it's not his daughter
[Music]
yeah
it's all pretty good
you could say it's going pretty good in
keemstar's world i hear some comments
that are curated
why is there a child in your kitchen
someone needs to investigate his phone
laptop and basement you know that's not
how entirely crazy
sentiment like i do think the fbi should
consider looking at his hard drives
because he's been doing a lot of texting
with girls
on instagram and [ __ ]
guys can we just take a moment to uh
clown on myself yes
i will always have one bro this midlife
crisis is in the flex you think it is
exactly my point
holy [ __ ] keemstar yeah your daughter
grew up so quick
that's his new girlfriend's classmate
anyway you get the idea okay
okay
okay all right let's go back up to mega
awesome nerd
uh reddit is back
kavanaugh will not be bullied oh my
goodness we got a whole video here
[Applause]
[Music]
and i will not be bullied by that
allegedly
yeah
yeah totally
so the uh
the um
deep fake of of your face on hulk looks
pretty good but this one is it's pretty
cursed yeah it's pretty curious
whoa that's a lot of
scandal it's so awkward
yeah so i just want to say oh that's a
funny interpretation of the events i am
not bowling i would never bully
kavanaugh
i was you know i have the listen
um kavanagh is a grown man i'm not
harassing him he's the ceo of a
figure social media company and he
happens to be engaged in litigation
against ethan right now he's a public
figure no less yeah
so
you know
i don't see the problem no problem there
bill gates epstein more [ __ ] bill
gates epstein [ __ ] did you not see this
i sent it early in the morning but i
know you were sick so maybe i passed
over this this is
this is something special um we are at
uh break time though so maybe we should
throw to that all right when we come
back from break we got plenty more to
talk about we got bill gates epstein
um
some new creepy family [ __ ] sounds
interesting gabby petito i'm gonna talk
a little bit about that you guys
probably heard all about her
and uh a little bit more but like i said
we're keeping it light and breezy today
i'm gonna count on my illness so
stay tuned we'll be right back time to
take a short break
guys if you're interested in investing
in cryptocurrencies but aren't sure
where to get started check out the
kraken app
with cracking you can buy and sell over
50 of the most popular cryptos like
bitcoin dogecoin and ethereum on the go
24 7. it's super easy to get started
just download the app create your
account and you're going to be investing
in minutes and one of the coolest things
about buying crypto through kraken is
that you don't need a lot of money to
try it out so even if bitcoin is trading
at forty thousand you can buy as little
as ten dollars worth on kraken just to
get your feed wet
find out for yourself why kraken has
been one of the highest rated places to
buy crypto for the last 10 years
visit kraken.com
h3 now to learn more or search for
kraken
in the app store thank you thank you
kraken we love you
i cannot wait to get home and put on my
me undies because
i'm sick i just want to go home and be
comfortable
i wear them out too because they're just
soft they're breathable they my fat ass
slips right into them and it you know
no i have to be fat to wear but i'm
saying i have extra needs i have special
needs
me andy's always accommodates you know
halloween's coming out they got
glow-in-the-dark underwear what the
frick
[Music]
good way to initiate some sexy time
what's up girl
dick is going
usually not usually not a good thing but
now it is
they've got five new prints to turn up
the terror
so summon them before it's too late
i love them
love me some me undies
whether you're out running a killer or
being abducted by aliens this halloween
be comfortable by the fact that your
undies are sustainable and soft and the
softest in town me and these are made
from natural fiber sourced from
beechwood trees making their micro modal
fabrics soft breathable and dangerously
cozy
get your spooky season up and haunting
with five new prints i see you my boo
trick and treat lazy bones and lazy
pumpkin
available in undies bralette socks
loungewear and sizes extra small through
4xl
big and beautiful
and there's a lot of options to consider
but make your decision quickly because
there's somebody right behind you ah
wow
mandy's has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15 off and free shipping hold
the phone
did it say that one more time yes
15 off and free shipping also here's a
promise if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason you could turn it
for your full refund
within 45 days so to get 15 off your
first order free shipping 100
satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com h3 that's meundies.com
h3 we love you
so many americans are experiencing
financial hardship this year but upstart
can help regain your footing and get
things back on track upstairs the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
already used upstart to get one fixed
monthly payment
upstart knows you're more than just your
credit score
and so it's expanding access to more
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan
and within five minute online rate check
you could see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand fifty
thousand dollars and you can receive the
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com h3 that's upstart.com h3
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application remember guys
that's
dot com slash h3
look i
know how much work goes into creating a
small business
it's tough tough stuff
and
going to the post office is just a lot
of time and time is money in that world
i know it's a cliche but it's true and
that's why stamps.com
is making
the easy mailing shipping right from
your home the same it's changing the
game
you're gonna save time and money with
stamps.com you're sending letters
packages for less and you're getting a
discounted rate from you sps ups and
more
um
everyone i know that's used stamps
including myself has had a great
experience
uh because they're simple convenient and
great for all businesses
since 1998 stamps.com has been an
indispensable tool for nearly one
million businesses
they bring the service of the us post
service and ups shipping right to your
computer whether you're an office
sending invoices a side hustle etsy shop
or a flow fully blown warehouse shipping
out orders stamps.com
is going to make your life easier all
you need is a computer a standard
printer no special supplies or equipment
are required within minutes you're up
and running printing official postage
for any letter any package anywhere you
want to send and you'll get exclusive
discounts on postage and shipping from
usps and ups once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or drop off
there's no traffic no lines cut the
confusion out of shipping with
stamps.com's new raid advisor tool you
can compare shipping rates and timelines
to easily find the best solution
so
if you want to save time and money go to
stamps.com there's no risk and with my
promo code h3 you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale with no
long-term commitment or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
h3dstamps.com
promo code
h3stamps.com never
go to the post office again two
hairline king is back
they hate me for my hairline
so meme of all of us with your hair
where is that we should show it we
should show that it was fun it's so
funny
yeah i will never take accountability
for anything wrong i ever do again
i will just write it off as haters who
are mad and jealous of my hairline
[Music]
oh no is reddit down again okay you know
what i it's in the whatsapp it's in the
whatsapp yeah i got it yeah so someone
from the subreddit photoshopped
my perfect hairline on all the guys to
see how it fits it's quite entertaining
i have to say
i sent in a discord mine is cursed as
[ __ ] yeah it doesn't really
it doesn't really work eh
so a b oh it did work okay i was about
to
about to goof on you
for sending a reddit link
but it worked look at that
it's fantastic
all right so let's start let's let's
actually take this seriously for a
minute
i thought dan looked pretty good but you
all say that's like mega curse i think
it's cursed as [ __ ]
you look like a woolly willy dude i
think dan's the only one that rocks it
what
ian's a drug dealer for sure yeah ian's
there it doesn't look right there's
something terribly wrong with that one
like it goes way too down on his
forehead
i look like a walnut
it doesn't flatter uav i don't know why
i've got around his head i think i don't
know
and then i actually think it looks good
on zach but they have to eliminate the
mullet
right i mean the major mullet that's the
joe exotic vibe dude right
yeah so what do you think the the
perfect airline isn't for everyone
no apparently it doesn't work
although if you ask my mom yeah that's a
good segue real quick i just wanted to
show
my
uh friends uh discovered that reddit
post on their own and were goofing on me
and one of them said that uh
it looks like this
monchichi manchi what the hell is a
manchi it's it was a doll that was
actually really popular in like the 80s
or something i don't know but i sent it
to the group chat and cam came back with
this pretty quickly that is kind of like
my hairline to be honest
i am a bit of a manchi
i'm on chichi
but yeah speaking of hairlines if you
want to segue into that yeah we're about
to talk about bill gates absolutely but
this morning
my mom
totally out of pocket man
we have a vip chat line with my parents
so if they ever want to call in
or excuse me
make a comment or something they have a
direct line to dan
pardon me one second
and so
my mom
messages
in this chat this morning something for
dan
i'll show it to you just out of the blue
straight out of pocket man
he goes hey dan this is my mom now this
morning
hey dan i just saw a video where this
guy was having little dots on his head
to mimic hair follicles that have been
shaved
when
went down the guy just looked like he
shaved his head and wasn't bald at all
it looked amazing just thought i'd share
it
i'll see if i can try to find it again
send me the send me that video it's in
the doc right below okay so then we said
well yeah send this in the video mom
sure dan by the way we've talked about
this procedure we've we've made fun of
fousey i think for oh right yeah yeah
because fousey got it and
yeah i personally
look to each their own but it doesn't
look that
[Music]
that convincing
yeah he got the tattoo and then he later
got it removed
wait really yeah he tried yeah
yeah i mean if you're totally bo maybe
it's good with like thin hair
but if you're totally bald it's just
looks like you
tattooed your dome i disagree i think it
looks real
i think if yeah i don't know i mean on
that particular guy i guess it looked
it looked decent
what i just find it
i think complexion matters a lot
yeah that could definitely well what do
you think about my mom just straight up
sending this to dan
just called sending dan
i found it hilarious i thought she was i
yeah i totally misread the conversation
when he brought it up
i thought she was suggesting something
for us to react to no no
no she was just giving me give me a
heads up in case i didn't know
it's hilarious
for the record dan definitely rocks it
though
yeah that's what i i personally think
people should embrace what they
how they look and work with it dan is a
beautiful bald king bald king baby and
um
listen i didn't ask for this hairline
it's just
[Laughter]
i must have had i must have been good in
a previous life
well your dad has great hair for his age
as well
yeah my grandpa died in the age of in
his 90s with a full head of
black hair right long line of beautiful
hair lines can i say
now is is there
because i've been hearing this basically
my whole life but it's one of those
things that just gets repeated i don't
actually know if there's any validity to
the whole you you inherit your
mom's dad's hair
is that right it could be true i've
heard that well my bullet my mom's dad
was bald at like 25. so it's just not
that surprising it could be truth i mean
it makes sense if it's like
um on that uh you know genetic children
or whatever it's a popular myth i'm
saying but it comes from both sides it
comes from both sides okay fair enough
and that'll mail us that dome
anyway we said well well mom
are you saying that dan should get this
that she says well i just know a lot of
guys are bothered by their hair i just
thought it was a cool option to bother
you
it's i know she's being sweet yeah your
mom is the nicest
yeah it's just awesome it's like boomer
town
but my mom she does that to all of us
did you see the subtle shade though
we're like asking the questions no no on
that last image the last image look at
what she says we like
say what do you think mom and she says
hold on i'm cutting your dad's hair
hold on i'm busy slack spit right
i'm going with that man with hair i
ain't got time for these bald questions
oh
dan is gonna be okay yeah me too she
said i'm vain if i could do something
like that i would that being said you
need to see someone up close who's had
it done
and get that artist only it's permanent
even though it will fade up you want to
be sure
fade up
i love how you're just egging her on too
if it's done right it could be amazing
what do you think damn she says
[Laughter]
she says i think you should do a small
patch in the back and see how it looks
right you know i would pay for it
would you yeah
i think i'll pass i don't know i've i've
i've embraced it at this point i think
it's really
then
absolutely
horrible
look horrible kind of part of my fear as
well
maybe a small patch down the middle
just like a mohawk yeah or landing strip
you know what you could do
you know you could do you know some male
pattern balding they just have the one
thing here just do the one tuft oh
interesting yeah not not oh it might be
being greedy yeah just one test you
shave your head right dad yeah
i mean i still have
like 70 of my hair to tell you the truth
but like you know i i've got like the
what my dad refers to as the yamaka spot
the kippah spot and then obviously the
hairline in the front has receded a
decent amount but i mean most of my head
does still have hair but it's just
patchy so it's just better to just
embrace it i love how committed you are
to that dome bro that dome is clean i
embrace that down but that being said
listen
uh the hair transplants technology i've
seen on some of these people is amazing
crazy so i would i would totally do that
if you know it was something i mean
what's the difference i get brace i got
braces when i was a kid so my teeth
aren't [ __ ] up i mean what's the
difference it's all cosmetic right i
looked into it when you know a few years
ago when i was still you know
denied reality yeah to just see like
what it would cost and it it's it's very
expensive is it really yeah what was the
quote you got
i never got one as far as to do a quote
but i i just looked into it and tens of
thousands or more
yeah i mean you see really wealthy
people with like yeah i mean you look at
elon musk and mesos or what basis is
bold as [ __ ] elon musk is a good one
he's like the best example because if
you see those pictures of what you were
describing of the single tuft he was
basically there like 20 years ago and
now he's got a full head of hair i mean
i don't know how much you pay for that
but man it is worth it it's worth every
penny
around like 18 000
yeah i mean not not many people can
afford that for some [ __ ] hair right
you need to take a trip to turkey that's
where they do it cheap
i swear that's where like everyone in my
hometown when i go get it remember the
billion dollar smile guy sure he's got
friends yeah
they take the hair from your
back right i think they take it from all
wherever you have hair and then like
literally follicle by follicle they
extract it and implant it into your head
it's amazing man
i got i got plenty of hair everywhere
else so i have lots to work with but if
they take hair from like
your what wherever else like your chest
let's just say i don't know but then it
will be like chest hair will look weird
i mean no they take it from the uh they
take it from the head right yeah like
the back of your head the back of your
head yeah fair enough they cut skin i
wonder if they could take pubes and put
them on my dirt
i guess you're right it would be a lot
more
wiry if it was uh body hair and i think
what they do is they have a little tool
where they literally nick out the
follicle and they leave little holes in
your dome that's why it's so expensive i
mean it's it's a
long very arduous procedure they
literally do it hair by hair it's
amazing that it like really holds too i
mean this has been a long time this
[ __ ] been walking around with
hair
right yeah there's a bunch of different
ways of doing it different um but god
bless i mean hey no hate i mean [ __ ] do
it man do you look good you mean he
looks great have you got the money yeah
he looks great i held off on on
embracing it for a while because i was
just i had never shaved my head before
and until you do it you don't know
what your skull is really going to look
like like that and i was afraid it would
just look weird um and when i finally
did i was like oh my head is kind of
like the right shape for having a shaved
head so i lucked out it looks good
you lay blue-eyed kratos
there's a kratos vibe there for
sure well especially since i did it i've
really
let my beard i used to i've had a beard
for a long time but i used to keep it a
lot shorter but now i've i've been
letting it grow you're out here yep
exactly
all right what's this bill gates epstein
nonsense i guess just you're just going
to do a live react to it right now so
this has been what happened recently
this interview came out last night
wow
wow reported at that time
that you had a number of meetings with
jeffrey epstein who when you met him 10
years ago he was convicted of soliciting
prostitution from minors
what did you know about him when you
were meeting with him as you've said
yourself in the hopes of raising money
uh you know i had
dinners with him uh
i
regret doing that
relationships with uh people he said you
know would give to global health which
is a uh interest i have you know nearly
enough philanthropy goes in that
direction
uh you know those meetings were were a
mistake they didn't result in
uh what he purported and i cut them off
you know that goes back a long
time ago now uh there's you know so
there's nothing new on that it was
reported that you continue to meet with
him over several years yo he's getting
pressed
billy boy ain't used to that kind of
scrutiny you haven't seen he could be
like do you know who i am [ __ ]
um
and that in other words a number of
meetings
um
what did you do when you found out about
his
background
well
and you know i've said i regretted
having those dinners uh and there's
nothing absolutely nothing new on that
is there a lesson for you for
anyone else looking looking at this
well he's dead so
uh you know in general you always have
to be careful uh
and you know the
you know i'm i'm
very proud of what we've done in
philanthropy very proud of the work of
the foundation
uh
you know
that's
that's what i get up every day and focus
on
bro what did he mean by that
is there a lesson to be learned from any
of this well he's dead so you got to be
careful keep your keep your
like what keep your mouth shut what is
that response he's like well
he was about to yap and we took him out
anyone else looking looking at this
well he's dead so
uh just saying you know in general
careful uh
in general you always have to be careful
your man was [ __ ] kids
be careful
he's dead what the hell are you talking
about
wow i've never seen him squirm like that
no he's used to always being the top dog
she really brought it to him pbs news
it's [ __ ] hard
sometimes someone else looking looking
at this
well he's dead so
uh just saying you know in general it
makes me think he's not dead
right that's what uh wendy williams said
she's like well he's dead uh-huh what do
you know
[ __ ] you always have to be
careful uh
and you know the
you know i'm i'm
very proud of what we've done in
philanthropy very proud of that wasn't
the question
that was not the question
well so his his answer she said what's
the lesson for you he said well he's
dead so you have to be careful
well she specifically said is there a
lesson here to be learned for you or
anybody else
and the response is well he's dead okay
so you got to be careful
don't get caught
i mean i'm trying to
trying to unpack that just saying he was
squirming though he knew he was bombing
yeah
well i mean how is he not coached on
that
they probably so
yeah they probably told the interviewee
because you know he has hordes of teams
and everything like no epstein [ __ ]
they said you could have bill on and
they say with no epstein [ __ ] right and
she probably tossed him a curveball he
wasn't ready for could be
because i don't i don't think he would
put himself in this position uh
willingly
yeah except so i included a link
underneath because obviously this gives
me major uh prince andrew vibes okay
like that epstein the epstein ripples
yeah
just saying
i do it with everyone
right
and you profusely sweating
and that she went on to have
baths possibly there's a slight problem
with with with with the sweating the
difference with this idiot is that he
literally came here to talk about he was
code and [ __ ] bombed
so bad this [ __ ] is definitely
skilled too
because
i i
have a
peculiar medical condition which is that
i don't sweat um or i didn't sweat at
the time i didn't sweat at the time
yeah so the back story is that
she
the girl who he apparently
uh tried i don't know how to put it but
s she did yeah so he has a girl from
epstein
and she was saying he was like sweating
and was nasty and all this [ __ ] she
remembers him sweating a lot and so his
defense is i didn't sweat at the time
i swear now
but
just so happens in the period of time
where these allegations took place i was
suffering from
a condition where i didn't sweat yeah
i'm pretty sure a lot of people dug up
photos of him like sweating like a pig i
mean i'm sure they did but you don't
even have to go that far this is like
the biggest [ __ ] hey everybody how
could it sweat
it's closed i didn't sweat at the time
and that was oh she
yes i didn't sweat at the time because
i um
had suffered what i would describe as an
overdose of adrenaline in the falklands
war when i was shot at
uh oh because he was such a hero [ __ ]
he was such a hero so
okay so people who are shot at don't
sweat
that's a very obscure lie
but i wonder i mean they went over this
i mean that was pro yeah that was a
calculated
move i mean maybe that is a thing like
adrenaline overdose that prevents you
from sweating yada yada i mean i don't
believe that that's real i simply it was
it was it was almost impossible for me
to
to sweat on that particular almost
impossible
this says in stressful situations cold
sweats are usually mediated by
adrenaline so you do sweat from
adrenaline it's just cold sweats
yeah so sounds like he maybe was
sweating at the time but
was he sweating or not
i'm who knows
the man says he wasn't sweating
you cannot convict me o lord in grace
for i did not sweat at the time
your grace i am accused of essay
my evidence is clear and undeniable
i put forth for your grace and the
parliament i could not sweat at the time
therefore she is clearly lying
i can sweat now of course
but not at the time
thank you
maxwell
prince and the girl
this is now is the
exhibit one your grace
here you will notice my brow is
extremely dry
this was in the miami heat and you'll
notice not a drop of
sweat
maxwell is looking a little red
uh the sun the heat is getting to her
but not me grace i am dry
as your graces uh
[Music]
90 year old um
[Music]
now here's exhibit b
you'll notice me dripping in sweat
but this was the time after i couldn't
sweat
there was a brief time during my time
with epstein where i couldn't sweat this
was well after that
ah your grace the it's opening shut
oh okay prince andrew
the evidence is clear
you are not guilty he could not ever say
this girl
my good boy does not sweat we all know
that
oh oh this was when a paparazzi had
thrown water at me
[Music]
i was not sweating your grace you know
me well i do not sweat
also i just noticed this uh
photo of him with the girl was from 2001
the falklands war i believe was in the
70s 2001 was the year of no sweat
everybody knows that 1982
we did not sweat in 2001 it's well
documented so i thought there was no sun
that year actually so for 20 years after
the falklands were he didn't sweat but
then immediately after that it was yeah
the known phenomenon
are you a doctor dan shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
the day that that um
we now understand is the date which is
the 10th of march uh i was at home uh i
was with the children
[Music]
why would you remember that so
specifically why would you remember a
pizza express birthday and being at home
because going to pizza express in woking
is an unusual thing for me to do
i remember clearly eating pizza express
on that day
it was a hot day and i was not sweating
i remember clearly no sweat and only
pizza that day
[Music]
it was a hot hot day at pizza express i
got a cheese pizza
with pepperoni with pepperonis
it was not one sweat on my brow
pepperoni again
[Music]
so it is clear your highness i am not
guilty of these horrendous crimes
he's very irish for british royalty
which is i highly understand that
the family
for not sweating
good morning my queens of tick-tock
above 18.
that guy has more respect than prince
andrew
that guy sweats
at least he's above 18. yeah so
thank you thank you peace and love
wow you know i think i did a faux pas
earlier i said we're going to keep it
light and then i said we're going to
talk about gabby potito
let's not talk about gabby potato okay i
think everyone's talked to talked about
it to death
yeah oh i shouldn't say that either
oh
i don't think anyone nobody would have
even said anything if you didn't point
it out
come on
[Applause]
terrible tragic
very sad very sad
the [ __ ] dan
i can't believe that guys if you hadn't
drawn attention to what you said nobody
would have ever thought twice about it
they would have they would have noticed
they would have noticed
what okay so you guys said
google
youtube playing with my kitty to get
reaction
yeah so just pull it up on your screen
you only put it on the shirts put it on
the shared screen i'm here live that's
not i'm not a cat and just type that
phrase in and see what you get
okay
playing with my kitty to get
reaction
with the thumbnails
playing with my kitty wait is that us
euphemism
it sure is yeah
[ __ ] down here keep
all of the look at the dates that these
were posted two weeks ago this [ __ ] is
can look it keeps scrolling
yo this is sick one million views
let me eat it bro youtube you're [ __ ]
slipping hard
playing with my quote kitty with the
exclamation mark to get my butt y'all
are [ __ ]
you guys watch these
uh i i browsed one or two of them to see
do they they're all the same thing i
mean it's obviously fake
okay but it is like no it's not like
overtly pornographic
sort of i mean i guess it kind of is but
look how many there are keep scrolling
yeah this is and these are all within
the last two weeks oh that's too graphic
bro
that shouldn't even be on the search
page look at that one
i'm anything like him because i love you
oh it is age-restricted all right
[Music]
and they're all the exact same video huh
yeah this is this is definitely one of
the crazier
youtube trends i've seen
how did you guys find this somebody on
the discord
messaged it or or put it in the
suggestions uh thing and
oh my goodness gracious they literally
just said go on youtube and search
playing with my kitty cam you got to
blur this one too
you see this kid down
yeah
getting my husband to eat it prank
goes good oh
excellent at least that one's a little
different but yeah it's just so i guess
one of these videos
is a hit and then everybody because like
the thumbnails are all exactly the same
hold on let me do um
sort by views
why don't i see the views far right uh
[Music]
upload and then views
sort by
man aren't you a youtuber yeah i think
they changed it i used to oh it's here i
couldn't see it
damn
oh so this okay so here this one is just
straight up faking my death in front of
a cat so that's fine
this one from three years ago
has 2 million
not that graphic then this one has 1.1
million from two weeks ago this is i
think i i suspect they might have set it
off well no look the one below it's from
a month ago that one has a million views
let me see what's their channel like if
it's all just playing with my kitty
memes
these guys these guys have the craziest
thumbnail
game look at this thumbnail it's chaos
throwing my hungry girlfriend food out
the window look at this thumbnail it's
oops please literally chaos
it's kind of epic thumbnail can't even
hate on that one
hmm
man
oh here's uh my son
i sent scoons after my 12 year old son
and here's his son
i didn't realize wait this is a family
channel yeah no that's his brother
how do you know that you you because i
know because up there there are a bunch
of videos that say my 12 year old
brother to the right i think it says it
okay well regardless
they are just kids though but yeah
it says shut the [ __ ] up punk
i hired a fine assistant to see how my
girlfriend would react
it goes what the [ __ ] is this
hi bae
what the [ __ ] is this
it's awesome
man here he is choking her until she
turns purple that's sick look at her
[ __ ] dumb
she's suffocating
you're such a [ __ ] it says and he's
choking her out bro
what this is this is next level what
y'all think about that one
you're up oh my god
the ass nope below it
adding another
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm down let's do it ask my girlfriend
to do it in the swimming pool i mean are
these monetized like are they making
money i mean sure it has to be
how we get demonetized from like the
[ __ ] they found the kitty beautiful
bruh
oh no this is age-restricted okay
oh jesus stop it
[Laughter]
sloppy toffee
we'll have to clean that up a little bit
yeah it's a little bit of a pg-13 yes
but so
all right well that's it for me it's a
short app i gotta go home and rest up
for tomorrow
so that we don't cancel again all right
there's a slight chance we might push it
to saturday
oh wait well we're gonna post it sunday
anyway we were gonna post a sunday so if
that happens it won't okay that's good
the audience won't be affected that's
good
fantastic fantastic
well guys i hope you enjoyed
this very short episode
with peace and love
this is your captain with a perfect
hairline reporting out
and we'll see you on
friday
bye bye bye
[Music]
you